As the post-credits scene in Avengers: Infinity
War and the final few minutes of her recently
released solo movie have proven, Captain Marvel
is like the Kim Possible of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe: call her, beep her, if you want
to reach her.
Major Marvel fans know the story: S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent Nick Fury paged Captain Marvel at the
tail end of Infinity War after Thanos snapped
his Infinity Stone-powered fingers, and killed
half of all life in the universe.
In Captain Marvel, set many years earlier,
Carol Danvers hands Fury his pager back before
she leaves Earth to help the Skrulls locate
a new home world, telling him she made extra-special
enhancements to his trusty communications
device and to only use it to contact her when
there's a, quote, "real emergency" happening.
Thanos decimating the universe is certainly
a real emergency!
No one denies this.
But what about all the other crises that have
gone down in the MCU?
Did they not necessitate a call to Captain
Marvel?
Exactly why did Fury wait until Infinity War
to page her?
We finally know the answers to all those questions.
Sort of.
Movie news site SlashFilm did the world a
favor when they asked Marvel Studios president
Kevin Feige in a recent interview why Fury
didn't contact Captain Marvel sooner — like,
say, when that gigantic wormhole barfed up
a bunch of aliens over Manhattan in the original
Avengers.
That event was so bad that the World Security
Council launched a nuclear bomb at the city.
Nick Fury had to run outside and fire an actual
bazooka at one of SHIELD's own planes to try
and stop it!
That's some rough stuff!
If Captain Marvel is the most powerful character
in the MCU, and if she's apparently strong
enough to help take down Thanos, why hasn't
she been spoken about in connection with the
Avengers until now?
Why hasn't she helped them out?
According to Feige, there are two explanations.
The first one is that Fury may not have considered
anything that went down before Infinity War
a genuine emergency based on the scale of
the chaos.
Aliens invading Manhattan?
Who cares?
It's just one city, right?
No big deal.
Killer robots threatening total world domination?
Psh, whatever, that sounds like something
Tony Stark should be able to fix with a quick
call to his IT guy.
"Hello, IT?
Have you tried turning it off and on again?"
Nick Fury actor Samuel L. Jackson backed Feige
on this particular explanation, chatting with
IGN about why Fury hasn't called Captain Marvel
before.
"We finally have an emergency that I feel
warrants her presence.
This is unprecedented.
How are you gonna fight that?"
Feige's second explanation is a little...hairier.
According to the interview, Feige discussed
Fury's super-pager, saying:
"[...] how do you know he never hit it?
How do we know he never pushed it before?
We've never seen him push it before.
That doesn't mean he never did."
Okay, maybe that's true?
We never saw him page her...but there's a
lot of things we never saw Nick Fury do.
We never saw him get eaten by a shark, but
it doesn't really make sense to accept that,
well, perhaps he did.
Anyway, it doesn't make too much sense to
speculate about the ins and outs of why Fury
may or may not have called his BFF Captain
Marvel over all these years.
That's because Avengers Endgame, which will
fly into theaters next month, will probably
address Captain Marvel's whereabouts in the
time between her solo film and the end of
Infinity War.
Not only that, but it should also explain
why the heck she didn't rush to the aid of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes when they weren't
feeling all that mighty.
And hey, maybe she'll show off some of the
pages Nick Fury did send her over all those
years.
Maybe he kept her up-to-date on those cool
Star Wars prequels she was missing while she
was flying around in space.
"Did Samuel L. Jackson ask for a purple lightsaber?
You bet your ass I did."
Avengers: Endgame opens in theaters on April
26.
Perhaps before then, Marvel will release a
montage of all the times Fury tried and failed
to get Captain Marvel to swoop in to save
the day.
A Marvel fan can dream.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.